hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I'm going to answer questions from
one of my readers Jackie who's asking
about how to connect with employees and
keep them accountable so a couple of
tips for you that might be helpful the
first is actually care about your
employees and this might sound obvious
but a lot of people a lot of employers a
lot of entrepreneurs are so tied up with
the day-to-day of writing the business
is stressful it takes up a lot of time
that all we care about from our staff is
do they get the job done and we don't
have to think about them as a person and
asked about their lives and what they're
up to and realize that you know they
have a life outside of just working for
you and the more you can connect to that
and the more you can get them to feel
like you actually care about them and
the more you actually do a care about
them the more they're gonna care about
you I want to do more for the business
and get more involved and see that
you're successful so with my staff I
always try to ask people what they're up
to try to participate in their lives you
know without being overbearing but the
more that they know that you care then
the more likely they're gonna care about
you so it's a two-way street and
obviously you want your staff to care
about you and care about the company the
next thing is trying to tie in what your
team is doing to the bigger picture
because often you know people can get
lost in the day-to-day of their job and
they don't see how it's helping
ultimately right as entrepreneurs we're
helping people we're delivering a
product or service that fulfills needs
and makes people's lives better but
often the people who are doing a lot of
the work they may not have any customer
interaction and they don't see how
you're helping people so the more you
can tie in what they're doing to the
bigger picture and make them realize
that the tasks that they're doing is
really important and is having a lot of
impact on people and is really valuable
the more likely they're gonna want to
stay and like their job and be more
accountable
also try to tie them into the bigger
picture of what their task is instead of
just saying do this this is your job get
it done the next thing and the last
thing I want to quickly talk about is
try to share your wins so a lot of the
people in your company again may not
have a lot of connection to the
customers they may not see how the work
that you're doing is actually being
useful and helpful and if they do a lot
of times it may just be complaint rights
of some of the people who are working
for me they'll be working with some of
our authors and and all they'll get as a
problem emails right most people don't
write in to say hey this is great
they're writing to say I'm having a
problem with this or can you help me
with that and so the in your employees
day-to-day lives all they're seen is a
negative and the problems and that's
what they're trying to solve and they
may not see all the great stuff that
you're doing so for my part of the
business I'll always get emails from
people saying hey thanks for that video
or thanks to a newsletter it was really
inspiring I really appreciate it now I'm
not more motivated than ever to want to
keep core of my business and that's
great that gives me a boost and I want
to keep doing the stuff that I'm doing
because of those comments and what I'll
do is I'll share that with my team so
that they see that hey you know we're
really having an impact here it's not
just the problems that we're getting
there's a lot of benefit that we're
doing is a lot of good that we're doing
and we're helping a lot of people so
more you can tie people into that and
share those wins the more likely they're
going to again like their jobs care more
about the business and be more
accountable as well so I hope that helps
you guys like the video please give it a
thumbs up and I'd also love to hear an
awesome feedback if you want to leave a
comment below the video and stay tuned
for the next episode
you